as we get closer and closer to a new
Stargate franchise hopefully
we have to start thinking about some of
the big questions that this new show
assuming it's a continuation will have
to answer and for me this might be the
biggest is the Stargate still a secret
or not
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
so the Stargate program
is it still a military secret kept from
the public or does everybody know about
it now this is a big question now we do
know what Brad Wright was planning for
this when he was preparing his script
for the pilot episode oh god well over
two years ago now he was going to make
the Stargate program known to the public
so everybody knew but what are the pros
and cons of that should it be a secret
or should it be known to the public
right well let's first of all think
about should it be a secret
first of all I've said this loads and
loads of times on this channel I want
Stargate I don't want Star Trek when it
returns and by that I mean Stargate and
Star Trek are different
in the Star Trek universe obviously it's
a utopian future it's lots of spaceships
lots of zipping around lots of very
high-end technology they still have
challenging storylines but the
technology and the Sci-Fi is
in a different Universe to what we know
in Stargate it was always chained to
reality it could be happening we could
actually live in a world where Stargate
was a reality and the teams really were
going off to all these different planets
but by the end of sg1 and SGA actually
the Towery were very powerful we had
some of the baddest spaceships in the
universe we were flying around kicking
everyone's ass we had some of the most
advanced weapons and Shields and all of
that beautiful technology from the
Asgard to exploit we were
technologically speaking virtually as
advanced as the Asgard or at very least
have the information we need to become
as advanced so we were touching on sort
of Star Trek levels of Technology
now that means that any new franchise is
going to have to carry on from that
point and it means that it's going to
feel a lot more like space-based sci-fi
than the Stargate series we were used to
but we have actually had that in
Stargate Stargate Atlantis was space
based sci-fi and we still loved it
Stargate Universe was obviously space
based sci-fi and even though that's a
little bit of a Marmite series people
either love it I mean some people
generally think Stargate Universe is the
best of the Stargates or they're not so
Keen I'm on the it was a bit boring but
it was getting better side of that fence
sg1 is my favorite but
SGU was space based sci-fi very much
like what we're going to see probably in
a new franchise but obviously the new
franchise can still go through the gate
Etc could still be based around a team
but how do you keep that element of
reality if the Towery are so Advanced
and so powerful I remember those rumors
about how there was apparently a store
cupboard at NORAD and it said Stargate
command on it because somebody loved the
show so much and knew that it was based
in reality so they you know mocked up
that little sign I don't know if that's
true or not I hope it is but that is you
know one of those little signs of how
well I love this show was and why one of
the reasons was for it to be so loved it
was because it was based in reality and
if they diverge from that
they're gonna have to be very careful
that it still feels like the Stargate we
love but how about if it was not a
secret
well to be honest because of everything
I've just said it makes total sense that
they would have to at some point release
this to the public and they tell the
public what's happening
for example
think about all of the technology that
we've amassed that could have power
reactors Shield technology transporter
technology and we have the technology to
matter replicate now thanks to the
Asgard and we have all of this
technology that could solve all or most
of the problems we have on Earth we are
giving macular reactors to people that
are not on Earth you know humans on
different panels of colonies all over
the universe we're giving nacho director
to people but we don't give them to us
we are still using coal and burning
fossil fuels when all of this technology
is available we are still killing our
planet
polluting our planet even though we have
this technology it doesn't make any
logical sense so the government would do
that now it did make sense initially
under sg1 but by the end of sg1 and the
beginning of SG universe
most of the planet's governments knew
about the Stargate program look at how
many different nations were represented
in the SGU and actually also the Ashley
Atlantis Expeditions Germany England
Russia China on and on and on
most of the governments knew now that
takes me on to my second Point most of
the government's new and governments are
really bad at keeping secrets now
America keeping a relatively small
secret like the Stargate program with
only a couple of hundred people working
at the SGC going through Gates okay by
the end of sg1 when the planet had been
attacked several times we were starting
to sort of go hmm really they've kept
this a secret still
really
they actually played on that in a few
Stargate episodes where you know it was
going to get leaked
repair for an extra
[Music]
I think the writers Brad Wright Robert
Cooper malozi so on and so on were
starting to realize actually this is
ridiculous so this is still a secret and
as I said in several episodes they
played up to that silliness
in an extraordinary new Sci-Fi series
starring dick Marlow as The Rock Colonel
Danny as a matter of fact it does say
goodbye
it doesn't make sense that we would have
all of this technology and not use it it
doesn't make sense that all of these
governments know the secret and it's
still kept a secret and again it doesn't
make sense that we would share that
technology with other races but not our
own
so
it is only logical for the Stargate
program to be public knowledge
spree
well that look familiar
I don't see it
the other thing is though this is my
final point
it's what Brad Wright wants
and I don't think whoever creates the
new Stargate series whether that be
penguin and a park or Mark Fergus or if
they scrap the whole thing and just go
back to Pride right
Brad Wright was the co-creator of this
series
he is Stargate as far as I'm concerned
and he has let it known that in his
script it was public knowledge and I
think if it's what Brad Wright wants
then maybe it's what Brad Wright should
get that means for me that the scar GATE
program has got to be public knowledge
and to be honest as well it doesn't
really change the show a great deal
it'll make a couple interesting episodes
where we get to find out how it was made
public knowledge and how Humanity
reacted to that it'll be interesting to
see what we then do with the technology
but it'll only be little Snippets it'll
be you know maybe a couple of little
episodes where they'll get mentioned but
it won't be actually a big thing for the
actual plots of anything moving forwards
imagine the end of sg1 the last couple
of Seasons if they'd have written in
that the become public knowledge would
have actually changed anything that
happened in those episodes
not really so I have to say as long as
it's done cleverly it doesn't have to
change anything
and any show that we get would actually
still be the same but
in some ways it would still be logical
and still grounded in reality because if
Stargate command was a reality
it would eventually have to become
public knowledge there that is a secret
they could never keep for that long
so it is only logical and only realistic
that the Stargate command would have to
become public knowledge
but guys while I was doing the live
video the other day I did do a poll and
I asked you lovely people what did you
think should this be a secret still or
should it be public knowledge and it's
been running for just over a week now so
let's have a look and the answers is
new Stargate series should Stargate
still be a secret still a secret to 61
known to by the general public 39 so
that had 797 votes
so you guys want it to still be a secret
but as I've argued does that really make
sense
get in the comments though guys and tell
me have I changed your mind at all or do
you still think it should be a secret if
that's how you voted and how do you
actually think they should announce it
if they do how should we see that should
it be something that's happened in the
last 10 years since Stargate SGU ended
or should it be something that happens
as part of the new series or a movie get
into the comments and tell me exactly
what you're thinking if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you can always go on to
patreon where we put most of our videos
on First and for a small fee each month
you can get to see them before everybody
else on YouTube and without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]